what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so I want to try my hand at an
experiment of sorts I want to talk about
like tasteless and terrible superheroes
that's a really good name for a series
tasteless and terrible superheroes
because as amazing as DC rebirth is and
as you know good as some of the stories
are coming out of all the all different
Marvel and model now to point out there
have been some really tasteless and
terrible creations by Marvel and DC over
the years and I want I want to bring
wipes I'm going to bring those to light
I want to bring you some of these so
we're going to testing the water here I
have no idea whether or not anybody
cares but in this video we're going to
be talking about section eight now the
important thing to remember here is that
in the mainstream Comics Marvel DC and
usually valiant most superhero teams
represent ideals of what we believe
heroes should be the best qualities of
humanity right like another brave
they're noble either they're beyond
reproach over the darker story lines
like Punisher driven by righteous rage
against evildoers in researching DC
Section eight I have found none of these
qualities if section eight originates
with the hitman comic series of the
mid-1990s when DC introduced the
bloodlines event now for those of you
guys who don't know the bloodlines event
was DC's version of activating mutants
and they explained this by having a
number of alien parasites attack human
beings and activate the meta-gene
and several people but Garth Ennis and
John McCrae who were the creative team
that came up with the hitman comic
introduced a lot of creative and
sometimes weird aura around hitman
fleshing out a highly evolved backstory
and a lot of it revolving around the
denizens of the cauldron which is
basically the Irish section of Gotham
City now I want to focus too much on
hitman I may actually do a video on him
later regarding how he fits into the DC
Universe properly I'm doubted but I
might but I do instead wanna focus on
the superhero team that first appears in
hitman number 18 in 1997 section 8 which
was led by a guy named six-pack now
section 8 takes their name for the
military moniker of being too crazy for
duty and the members of section 8
illustrate this all too well of course
the series even hitman is a parody of
sorts with a mix of dark comedy action
and even mysticism brought in probably
due to Garth Ennis his work on creature
gay man in Hellblazer but when we're
introduced to the team they're
effectively split on and may have had
some sort of superhero history how much
is not really known by the leader
who's basically prone to drunken
hallucinations now the full section a
team consists of six pack himself as the
leader boy no excelente
the defenestrate ur dog welder friendly
fire Jean baton baton flem Jim and
shakes now regarding six-pack I don't
even know where to start with this guy
you know how it like family reunions
like everybody has that drunk uncle that
makes all these outrageous claims
without like past glory but he's just
really just like a middle-aged
pot-bellied drunk guy that is six-pack
to a team he's dressed in a raggedy
superhero outfit with a cowl in a cape
but it's three sizes too small and his
beer belly sticks out beneath it the
greatest thing about six-pack though
whose real name is actually Sydney spec
is that during his drunken ramblings he
routinely makes outrageous claims like
the fact that he fought doomsday in vain
at the same time now he has no actual
superpowers unless you consider his
ability to consume an inhuman amount of
alcohol to be a power his abilities are
stemming a stealth an unknown combat and
he's an expert with a broken beer bottle
that's amazing boy now excelente is
ridiculous his superhero ability is that
he fights evil with the power of
perversion so I guess he has that going
for him the only two words that he's
ever shown saying are either excelente
or bueno usually followed by a creepy
chuckle or laughs he's a stealth expert
and most of his battles happen off
screen after he appears behind an enemy
and is followed by a scream effect now
in one instance a Gotham City newspaper
shows that one of the people that bueno
had snuck up behind had been like
fatally violated so there's that and
when sixpack finally locates him to
reform a team he finds him in an adult
theater now the defenestrate er is
basically an Arnold Schwarzenegger
knockoff who carries around a window
which he then throws people through he's
basically Arnold's character and tomato
- except he's less awesome and he throws
evildoers and policemen through the
window he carries which lands him a
standard Arkham Asylum even his last
words reflect Arnold Schwarzenegger
Winnie perishes now we come to section
eights most iconic character dog welder
now dog welder fights crime by welding
dead dogs to criminals
faces hence the name I told you you guys
this is this is tasteless
- listen terrible superhero is
ridiculous in the comics he never speaks
he lives in an alley and sets traps for
stray dogs and many surprises criminals
welding a dog to their face the reader
never gets to see who he actually is or
reveals a name for the character as his
face is always covered by a welding
helmet he's actually the only section a
character who wasn't completely created
by Garth Ennis and John McCree as Steve
Dillon who was a longtime Garth and his
collaborator came up with a concept of
dog welder now steve dylan unfortunately
passed away in October of 2016
due to complications from a ruptured
appendix but dog welder despite the
messed-up origin one Wizards best new
comic book character of the year in 1997
now friendly fire would easily be the
most powerful member of the group except
that he has bad aim and he's always
really nervous meaning that more often
than not his shots hit his allies with
his powers instead of his enemies his
superpower is flame control which he can
shoot from his hands but he eventually
meets a tragic end at his own hands
accidentally shooting himself in the
face with his flame control powers and
section eights final battle now this
brings us to john baton baton who fights
evil with the power of french enos john
is over the top French speaking French
in panel without translation armed with
a baton and a loaf of French bread how
amazing is that he also throws rings of
garlic and onions and enemies to blind
or stun them his abilities are
exceptional agility as he's always
leaping about and hand-to-hand combat in
weapon expertise widows baton and French
bread now most comic book readers
believe that he's a parody of Marvel's
Batroc the leaper who is also French and
is always bouncing around so it stands
to reason that would be the case but the
next person is flem Jim and it does seem
like he has an actual power albeit a
pretty disgusting one flem jim has the
ability to spit globs of glue like slim
at his enemy he also appears as a bald
fin man in a green suit purple Domino
mask and blind suffocates or disgust bad
guys now the last and really the least
of the list is shakes this is where we
really start getting into the whole
tasteless nature shake appears as a
homeless bum who has a combination of
Tourette's and Parkinson's disease and
that he can't stop shaking and his words
are barely coherent that's the most
tasteless thing that I've ever heard of
in a comic book
but he's primarily comic relief in a
parody comic meaning that he's a
frequent target of friendly fires fire
blasts and
mishaps he's also six-packs closest
friend on the team now despite the
seemingly unheroic abilities that each
member of the team possesses they
actually played a key part in several
storylines of the hitman comic and the
ace of killer storyline they team up
with hitman detective Tegel and NAT the
Hat as well as Catwoman and take on the
mob actually managing to kill several
mafia soldiers now it isn't the only
time that Section eight comes to hit
man's rescue as in the Hitman Lobos
storyline Section eight rescues hitman
from space bounty hunter Lobo now what
they do here is absolutely insane they
wait until Lobos passed out and then
they make it appear as if Lobo and Wayne
Oh excelente got married in a drunken
ceremony and all the members of section
8 and hitman himself have copies of a
ceremony that will go to the Justice
League among others if Lobo kills any of
them they literally blackmail Lobo by
making it look like he got married to a
guy and so Lobo basically just kind of
bails out in disgust now toward the end
of the Hitman series is where Section
eight would meet its end around the time
of hitman number 34 Ennis was hired to
write a comic and Superman 80 page giant
number 1 this section entitled how to be
a superhero is where an alcohol annulled
6-pack dreams that Superman asked him to
accompany him as he patrols metropolis
along the way Superman lectures six pack
on the ways of heroism such as not
burning down prisons or stabbing
would-be muggers with broken beer
bottles now section eight would go on to
meet his apparent end in hitman number
51 and 52 in this story section 8 was on
the verge of breaking up as
friendly-fire pointed out that most of
their exploits were a result of 6 patch
alcohol-fueled allusions now at the time
scientists from engine Peak accidentally
released the multi angled ones those who
don't know
the most the angled ones are the demons
of the DC universe and they also appear
in the Marvel Universe as the many
angled ones or the giants of Cthulhu and
other media or what have you but within
this case the faceoff with the demons
was disastrous for section 8 most of the
team die by demon hands or accidentally
killed themselves among the examples are
sheiks who accidentally grabs a hand
grenade from six-pack and runs into a
gas station to blow up as many demons as
possible or maybe Jesus does a Backson I
have no idea but he was a strange
character to say Delisi was weird but
six members died nearly immediately from
the demon attack now as the demons
descend on six-pack they're amazed when
fire from a blade
does not consume it now whether this is
from an actual special ability or blind
luck or something else is not really
known but it is noticed by the demons
and so in the confrontation six-pack
tells the demons that he would give his
life to save the world from the demons
themselves because that's what
superheroes do in response the demons
more of a farce than an actual deal
offer to let him leave with him with a
wager being that he would offer up his
soul against leaving the entire earth
alone now whenever six-pack encounters
in Hell or whatever plays the DC
multi-angle ones are actually from
happens off-screen all that's known is
that at the end of hitman number 52
six-pack has a statue built in a park to
honor his sacrifice and it's later shown
that six-pack is alive and attending an
a a meeting implying that he defeated
the multi-angle ones or it could be an
implication that all the superhero
exploits were nothing more than drunken
delusions it's sort of left up to the
reader to decide what exactly happened
but aside from six-pack the only member
of section 8 who appears to have
survived the encounter with the multi
angled ones is bueno excelente who's
last panel shows him getting revenge on
the scientist responsible for releasing
the mostly angled ones in Gotham but
that is basically section 8 from DC
Comics tasteless and terrible
superheroes man there's some tasteless
stuff in here but I'm really kind of
curious to see how people respond to
this if you guys are new here to come
let's explain which you guys are the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and leave a comment down
below let me know if you want to see
some more stuff like this I'm hoping
that a lot of the other ones that I come
across aren't as tasteless is this
releases you know as some of the guys
and this but yeah it's it's it's weird
it's just one of those strange things
when writers come up with weird stuff
anyway guys we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I'll
catch you all later please
[Music]